well good morning everybody this week
striking gold focuses on the outdoor
hockey games the nhl has pulled off this
event 31 times
31 outdoor games and again las vegas
always seems to figure
in those historic or unusual events and
this was really both
for the very first one it was staged
here in vegas and caesar's palace back
in 1991
it was september and when they dropped
the puck it was 84 degrees boy it was a
big deal also sold out
over 13 000 hockey fans were in
attendance on an outdoor
makeshift rink in a game between the
kings and rangers
and of course the star on the ice that
night was wayne gretzky
now 30 years later in las vegas has its
own nhl team
and the knights will play the avalanche
and the star who knows might be
marc-andre fleury
maybe the nhl should be the star we'll
have to wait and see one thing we do
know
all the players and coaches are going to
have fun they'll take it in they'll try
to come by with two points a win that's
a goal of theirs
they got to get some goals coach peter
deboer gives his impression
of what might unfold on an outdoor sheet
of ice with mother nature dictating
you know wind snow uh the condition of
the ice
depending on on what the weather's like
all those things are going to come in
play and i think we expect that we
expect it not to be perfect condition so
um you know i think
it shouldn't change the fact that uh i
think you're gonna have two teams that
really want to win they know
you've got a national audience watching
this game and
for me you know sometimes in these type
of games
uh you want to keep it a little simpler
than you would in a normal
game uh you know limit the the number of
passes keep the puck moving
you know in direct lines as opposed to
making cute plays
just because of some of the conditions
all right and we will be in tahoe later
today with the vegas gold knights as we
share with you some of the sights and
sounds
of this first ever event not only for
the knights but for the nhl as well they
may never build another rink
on a golf course fairway might never
happen again guys back over to you
oh that's going to be so fun and it's
going to be beautiful the views from
there i understand are
spectacular yeah i mean think it's a bad
view in tahoe